all right let's get uh the view now of
Michelle O'Neill because this time last
week all the talk was of the PM's deal
with the EU over Northern Ireland uh
protocol seemed to get a decent enough
reaction from most Parts but of course
the big question is what do the dep do
the largest unionist party in Northern
Ireland they say they won't rejoin power
sharing if they're not happy well the
largest party at Stormwind ishim Fain
and its leader there would have been
first Minister that's Michelle O'Neill
she joins us live now uh thank you very
much for being on the program this
morning has Rishi sunak negotiated a
good deal for Northern Ireland
well I think we've all had the best part
of a week now to reflect on the deal and
I think it's fair to say that the
general assessment has been cautious
welcome I think in the first instance
people welcome the fact that a deal has
actually been achieved that both sides
have signed up this is something that
this is a departure from the previous
approach to the British government to
take unilateral action so I think it's
fair to say that in all of my
engagements throughout the course of the
last week particularly with the business
community that they feel this is a a
good deal and something in which they
can move forward on something that they
think that now leads to the restoration
of the executive which is where we all
should be in the aftermath of last
mayor's Assembly election and I think
that's where we need to be noted to
maximize the huge economic potential
that we now have as a result of having
access to both the EU and the British
Market
the it's interesting that you say you
think that overall it's a deal that
should be welcomed particularly by those
in the business Community who feel
positive towards it the dep is still
considering it Christine Harris says
he's optimistic but of course they do
still have concerns uh about whether or
not Northern Ireland has been treated in
exactly the same way as the rest of the
United Kingdom particularly when it
comes to EU laws can you understand why
the unionists may still have concerns
okay I think at the end of the day we
all have concerns
um you know with initially a way back
whenever brexit came about we voted to
reject Braggs that we wanted to stay
within the European Union we sought to
find protections and mitigations against
the hardest impact of it that came in
the form of the protocol and then we've
had this whole period of uncertainty
instability unilateral action by the
British government and quite frankly
we've been treated as collateral damage
by success of British governments and
successive Tory leaders so I think the
fact that we now find ourselves in this
position today
where there's been a large body of texts
an agreement has been reached the
negotiation is complete it's now done so
I think where we all need to be focused
on is yes we have to work through the
detail and yes you know we do have some
concerns but we work our way through
that but we equally can do that on
tandem with having a restored executive
and I believe that's where we all should
be because right now we've had no
executive since last mayor's election
it's not good enough for people who are
dealing with across the living crisis or
people who are struggling to get seen in
the Health Service because our health
services in crisis so I think we can do
more than you know one thing at a time I
think that all parties should be back
around the executive table and actually
restore an executive immediately you
can't go on in an endless period of
scrutiny of the text
I want to talk to you about about the
restoring of the executive a bit later
but you know you'll stay there about
working through the details I guess what
the dup and some unionists would say is
look this isn't just details for them
this is you know the whole belief that
they have in being a unionist that
Northern Ireland should be treated by
exactly the same way as the rest of the
United Kingdom the same laws should
apply it should be exactly the same as
whether you're in Glasgow or Newcastle
or London so it's not just details for
them is it
unfortunately I mean I think there's no
consistency there because and many times
over the past particularly when it comes
to rates issues the dep have been happy
to be on a different side to what has
happened in Britain however I take on
board everybody's concerns I think
that's you know legitimate people are
entitled to express their concerns but
where we need to be right now and what
is needed from the dup right now is
leadership because they know that they
deliberately took a tactic
um they decided to walk away from the
executive in order to influence the
negotiation but the negotiation is now
complete so there's no reason for them
to stay outside of the executive they
should be back around that executive
table taking all the matters of the day
and then yes let us work through all of
the detail but that's in the deal
because as I said I equally have some
concerns
particularly around the statue of a
storm or break and what that might look
like and how it can be used because I
certainly don't want any dealing to
create you know replace a problem with
the problem but these are things we can
do whilst also being in the executive so
I think that's where the wider public
here or the local community here uh the
people on the ground are saying well a
deal is now done so get back into the
executive and that's where I am ready to
be because Sophie we're about to embark
on a period where we will celebrate 25
years of the Good Friday agreement that
is something that's an enormous
achievement something that we should all
be very proud of and something that
again because we now have this deal
because we have access to both markets
because we have huge economic potential
we now need to be and bringing all that
International attention to our place
because of the celebration of the Good
Friday agreement we could have a
presidential visit from the United
States we could have this to become a
real economic Catalyst that will
actually grow our economy create jobs
better jobs this would be an opportunity
if this opportunity was missed that
would be so much so so detrimental to
what we could achieve in this period by
working together
are you talking about the anniversary of
the Good Friday agreements would you say
that the agreement and the peace in
Northern Ireland is in a strong place or
in a fragile place now
absolutely in a strong place I mean we
have come lips and bones in the last 25
years I am very proud of what our
society has achieved I am very proud but
collectively we all have achieved
because the when you think back to 1998
and where we are today in 2023 it's
completely transformed for the better
that's something that we should charge
and hold on to which is why whenever
brexit came about we said that the Good
Friday agreement and brexit weren't
compatible that you couldn't score that
Circle but we are where we are today and
and the one thing that the business
Community will be very strong on in
these common months when we have this
huge opportunity with the new US Envoy
being appointed to focus on the economy
with our Good Friday agreement
anniversary we need to be in that
executive because we need to be doing
delivering good public services for
people whilst also a villain of the huge
opportunity I found myself this week
actually strangely agreeing with the
British prime minister because whenever
Rishi cynic talked about the unique
position of the single market and the
British Market having access to both
markets that is a huge opportunity for
us something that I'm quite sure is an
Envy of many people who live in Britain
you talked earlier to Chris heating
Harris about Scotland and Wales and
potential that they would also want to
see that that same thing but the British
government gave that away but we now
have this unique selling point and I
want to maximize that and I want the
Good Friday agreement anniversary to
that on top of that um opportunity to be
huge countless for investment here and
that should not be most of the dep can't
go on in this being endlessly yes
everybody wants to do their due
diligence but then get around the table
and work and make politics work with the
rest of us do you think the dep are
serious about wanting to enter a power
sharing
well that's a question you're going to
have to put to them
um we obviously had a very historic
election last May of the very first time
a nationalist was returned as first
Minister and I am in the position of
first Minister designate the duper
failed to honor that election to this
point but I still um hope that they will
get to that point because the parish
earn is how politics works in the north
we have especially unique circumstance
because of the Good Friday agreement and
there isn't any other alternative in
fact probably the alternative to
um Parish room would be some arrangement
between the British and Irish government
so I think where the public want us to
be is in the executive because otherwise
we're sitting on public services and our
public sector workers and our economy is
all being held around somebody and
policies that are taken in London by the
Tories who quite frankly have trained us
as collateral damage the whole way
through the past brexit a bit
um Cuisine Harris in the program earlier
said that look he hopes that what will
happen is the DP will back the deal and
they will go back into Power sharing but
he did say that if that doesn't happen
he is prepared to order another election
do you support him in that
but firstly I want to be an executive
that is my priority that's where I'm
going to continue to work
um to get to that point I think that's
what the public and want and expect of
their political leaders but you know the
Democratic rules are that if the
election isn't result isn't respected
then you do go to another election so I
mean I hope you don't get to that point
but if we do then we stand ready to
fight such an election
okay thank you very much for being on
the program uh this morning a really
interesting team thank you for Michelle
O'Neal there